Welcome back to human emotion.
So today we're going to conclude
our discussion on psychophysiology.
And essentially going back to
the question we started with,
which is to what extent is our heart
really a window into our soul and our
emotions?
So we're going to do so today by starting
out with an exercise to conclude our
discussion on the
psychophysiology of emotions.
So what I'd like you to do is take out
a piece of paper and the pen and think
about a time in which you
felt a really strong emotion.
So maybe you felt really happy or excited,
maybe the rice sad,
maybe very nervous or scared.
Try to identify one moment
that really stood out to you.
And as you think in this moment, I want
you to answer three questions about it.
So what did you notice in terms of what
triggered it or what was the illicit her
second,
what did you notice happening in your
body where you aware of your heart racing?
Were you aware of your
palms getting sweaty,
where you're aware of your
breathing becoming more rapid?
And how long did this last?
So I'd like you to pause,
take a moment to write this down.
And when you're done,
you can resume the video
where we go through our final
lecture today on emotions
and the body.
So today we'll wrap up our discussion of
psychophysiology in our third component,
looking at our final, uh, sort of
discussion into the question of,
is our blood and sweat really a window
into understanding our tears and our
deepest fears.
And here we'll talk about two main
themes that are emotion specificity.
So how much can we really map specific
physiological profiles onto unique
motions as well as this idea of coherence,
or how well does our heart racing and
our skin temperature increasing actually
map onto what we would subjectively
report we're feeling in the moment.
So with today,
we'll start first with this
question of emotion specificity.
And here what we'll start with is looking
at this question of whether or not
different emotions actually have different
autonomic or physiological profiles.
So some of you might remember this
table that we've introduced at different
points throughout the course and
earlier on in our discussion of
psychophysiology. So this is a table, um,
that you'll see more in readings by
Bob Levenson that really advocated for
what's called the sort of
emotion specificity hypothesis.
And this hypothesis suggested that
for many of our most basic emotions,
we should have unique and
distinct profiles, um,
a physiologic corresponding in
our autonomic nervous system.
So here you would see anger is uniquely
associated with Bozzo dilation and pupil
expansion. You should also see things
or sorry, Vaseux um, yeah, dilation,
you would see reddening in
the skin. You're but blood
vessels bulging, you know,
your pupils actually constricting,
right? With fear. By contrast,
you see vasoconstriction,
sweat, glands activating.
This will lead to changes of seeing sort
people becoming Pale, you know, sweating,
clammy palms,
higher skin conductance or sweat,
sadness associated activity.
And the tear glands,
right discuss is different
from all of these.
We see activation in the salivary glands
where people are actually salivating
and drooling when they're
feeling disgusted.
And then happiness is one of the most
interesting and mysterious emotions to
date we see associated with activity in
the Vegas nerve or the parasympathetic
nervous system.
Um,
and people will describe this
tightness in their chest or goosebumps.
So what we're seeing here is really
specific kinds of physiological changes
associated with distinct emotions.
Um,
and what you have to ask though,
you saw on that table there
that have the emotions we have,
there was only one on the bottom and that
was just happiness, broadly construed.
So emotion specificity really took
flight by looking at differences among
different kinds of negative emotions.
So answering the question,
in what way does our body change?
And we're feeling anger
versus fear versus sadness.
And not until very recently.
So just in the past, you know,
five years even have people even begun
to try to understand what way different
kinds of positive emotions actually
look differently in the body.
So we know overall that people have
associated experiences of happiness with
activity in the
parasympathetic nervous system.
But what have you take this broad umbrella
of positive states and try to look
and see if they're different. So our
positive feelings, like excitement,
different from positive feelings of
love or pride. So, in other words,
the question you've been seeing here,
what about differences
among positive emotions?
Do we see support for this emotion?
Specificity hypothesis there?
So here, this is um, a paper that
I worked on with my colleagues. Um,
we're began to try to look
at this question by looking
at positive emotions at
rest and we found that what you see
here is that increased activity of the
parasympathetic nervous system.
So you measure this using Rsa,
which we talked about earlier actually
seem to really index important aspects of
individual differences
in positive emotionality.
So in this study we found for example,
that higher degrees of Rsa at rest
actually predicted even at these,
you know, eight month outcomes,
greater increases and you know,
positive emotionality.
So for one,
what we see is that there
are physiological measures
that seem to map onto
positive emotionality and
they even longitudinally
predict greater increases in
positive emotionality.
But as you can see here,
this is really talking about positive
emotion as a whole. So again,
what about distinct kinds
of positive emotions?
Do they look different physiologically?
So by and large,
this is a field that is still very new
and has a lot of unsolved mysteries.
Um,
so what I'll be presenting to you some
data that was recently published in 2011,
the very first study to look at distinct
autonomic profiles among positive
emotions. And I think what's
exciting about this, as it opened up,
it opens up an entire door of research
to more further these mysteries.
Um, but it also brings up
a lot of questions too.
So this was a study done
by Michelle Shiota, um,
a professor at Arizona State University
where she looked at a broad variety of
physiological measures here.
So we have heart rate projection period,
skin conductance response or
electrodermal activity, respiration,
Rsa, again, that's respiratory sinus
arrhythmia as well as blood pressure,
mean arterial pressure. And here
she looked at this in response to,
as you can see,
here are five different categories of
distinct positive emotional stimuli.
So people watched different emotionally
evocative films that really mapped onto
emotions of enthusiasm,
love, a attachment style,
love and nurturing style of love,
amusement and awe.
And hear what I have highlighted in
these black arrows are significant
differences that emerged
that differentiated each
of these five emotions from
one another and an upwards Arrow indicates
an increase in that of activity in
that physiological channel and a
downwards Arrow indicates a decrease.
So what can we learn from this?
Someone will walk you through the findings
slowly and then I want you to think
about toit extent.
This actually makes sense to you.
So the last time you felt
enthusiastic or you felt amused,
did this seem to map onto
your own bodily states?
So let's start first with amusements.
So if you look here,
what we're seeing with
enthusiasm, uh, sorry, thieves.
Yasmine is increase in skin conductance
response and a decrease in Rsa.
So in some ways it seems surprising,
right?
Because we thought that happiness was
associated with an increase in Rsa.
The way that the author argues that this
makes sense is that enthusiasm is the
state of excitement and joy.
And it's supposed to promote the sort
of pursuit of rewards, sort of, uh,
increased activity in what's called
the behavioral activation system.
And so as you're getting really excited
to sort of go after that reward and
obtain it, what you really want is to
get your body mobilized. You want to get,
you know,
your skin conductance up and you want to
sort of turn down your parasympathetic
nervous system.
So excitement might actually be a really
unique emotion and then it's actually
associated with getting that sympathetic
activity up and running so you can go
pursue and get that reward. When we think
of love. So you think of attachment,
right? So maybe it's an attachment
to a romantic partner. Um, you know,
and this is really interesting because
what they suggest for example, um,
in this research here is you also see
an increase in heart rate and a decrease
in Rsa. So again, what we're
seeing is body bodily mobilization.
When we look at discreet or
specific kinds of positive emotions.
So they would argue that this attachment
kind of love it was perhaps mobilizing
your approach behavior to go
seek out a potential mate, right?
And sort of engage them with you and that
you can't just be sitting and resting
and digesting.
You need to kind of get up and go out
there and try to pursue that potential
mate or attachment partner.
We look here at nurturant love,
we see an increase in heart rate and
an increase in respiration. So, um,
nurturant love actually is a
bit of a physiological mystery.
We don't quite understand why
the body changes in that way.
So nurturant love you're thinking of
the love you might feel towards a young
child or some people who are pet owners
will say they feel this way towards
their dogs or their cats.
Why is our heart racing
and we're breathing faster
when we're sort of cued to
see images of those things is an
exciting but really unknown mystery.
And I love for you to think about how
you would hypothesize, you know, uh,
this story to sort of make sense,
um, in your own understanding of uh,
nurturant love when we get to amusement.
One of the key differences here that
really picks out amusement is an increase
in respiration.
And if you think about the last time you
laughed when you were feeling amused,
what happens when we laugh?
So we talked about this earlier in class.
What happens when you laugh as you're
actually engaging in a series of very
rapid, very short breaths. So
essentially when you're amused,
you're laughing and that
causes your respiration rate
to pick up, not surprising.
Right? And then finally there's
this magical and mysterious
emotion of awe. So Ah,
is supposed to be this emotion that
picks up a sense of wonder and amazement
sort of being around something
bigger than the self. Um,
and this was sort of in contrast to
what I think the authors hypothesized.
So,
um,
this is interesting because what we're
seeing here is it's not leading to a
decrease in physiological arousal,
but it is consistent some ways with
this sort of cardiovascular undoing
hypothesis of amusement. So in other
words, what we're seeing here, um,
in some ways, uh, you know,
is the sense in which we're sort
of disengaging our parasympathetic
parasympathetic system,
but we're breathing more rapidly and
we're even seeing to some extent, um,
and increase in pep actually means
a decrease in sympathetic activity.
So we're seeing in some way,
uh,
is able to slow our sympathetic
nervous system down, right?
Maybe to help us sort of take in the vast
wonder of things around us. So again,
this is the one of the first studies
ever done and I'm excited to think about
all the new studies that may come
after this and start to look at emotion
specificity in the whole landscape
of broader positive emotions. So,
and I want to turn to emotion coherence.
And again,
if you remember from way back when we
first talked about what is an emotion,
we talked about what are
different features of emotions,
sort of what are the core constituents
of what makes an emotion and emotion.
And one of the definitions that's proposed
by one of the most famous figures and
emotion Pollock men, um, when he tried
to answer this question, he said, well,
there's these, you know, kind
of six fundamental features
of what is an emotion.
And one of them that's taking
for granted is coherency.
So this is the idea that we should see,
um,
all of our different channels of
emotion, our behavior, our physiology,
our subjective quality of what it's like
to feel an emotion that these systems
work together and they come
online together at the same time.
So the minute you feel an emotion,
your physiology should kick in and
should also see an accompanying facial
expression.
But here people have actually begun to
question this basic premise of what is an
emotion saying really our
emotions really coherent.
And one of the first studies that tried
to look at this looked at whether or not
our physiological,
you know,
responses that we've talked about in these
lectures actually are coherent or map
onto subjective reports of how
people are actually feeling.
So let me show you what some of
these studies have looked like. Um,
so for example, what we're going to
be looking at here in these studies,
in other words,
is to what extent does our physiology,
so an internal physical sensations, to
what extent do they map onto the quality,
uh, you know, at the top, sort of
what does it like to feel an emotion?
Do they actually cohere to,
they actually increase and
decrease together or are
they completely mismatched?
So here we're going to ask the question,
our emotions really coherent and
where's the empirical evidence?
So here this was work pioneered by IRS
mouse and colleagues who took people into
the lab and looked at emotion
coherent systematically.
So she had people come in and watch
emotion films while sitting at a computer,
positive, negative and neutral films.
And while they're watching these films,
she measured second by second assessments
and changes in their heart rate.
She also looked at using a continuous
rating dial moment by moment,
self reports of how a person was stealing
from very negative to very positive.
And she was able to take
these two measurements of
heart rate and continuous, uh,
self-reported assessments of emotion to
be able to look at to what extent we see
coherence or correlations
between moment by moment,
changes in heart rate and moment by
moment changes and how people self report
their feeling states.
And the upshot of the work by Iris
Nelson colleagues from this sort of
complicated,
uh,
correlation table that you see here is
that there's at most moderate coherence
on average, you see the highest
coherence between people,
self-reported experience and their
external expressions of behavior.
But since we're talking
about psychophysiology,
we see almost no match or coherence
between people's physiological states and
either their subjective experience using
the rating dire we saw earlier or their
outward displays of emotional behavior.
So really it seems to be the case that
emotions might not be as coherent as we
just assumed them to be.
Now researchers interested in looking at
whether or not this was really true for
everyone conducted a really interesting
study here and this has done by Jocelyn
z and colleagues at UC Berkeley where
they looked at coherence using a similar
paradigm,
looking at associations between heart
rate and self reported emotion and looked
at different kinds of people to see,
well maybe emotions are more coherent
and some kinds of people than others.
So here you can see they had healthy
control adults who showed the lowest
coherence followed by two
really interesting groups
of people that are thought
to have a sense of increased
bodily awareness. So the,
these were dancers and
meditators and as you can see,
they found meditators had the highest
degree of coherence between what they
reported feeling and what their heart
rate actually showed with dance or
somewhere in between,
in between.
So this suggests to some extent that the
greater bodily awareness you may have
and the greater sort of internal
awareness of your own mental states,
the raider coherence you're going to
show between your body and your mind.
So interestingly,
there may be coherence,
but maybe better for some than others
in terms of this almost mind body
connection.
Okay.
So with that, I want to conclude
now with our takeaway questions,
talking about motion
specificity and coherence.
So what is the physiological evidence
in support of emotion specificity,
especially for the basic emotions we
first talked about that were primarily
negative emotions.
Okay.
Then what is the physiological
evidence in support of emotion,
specificity for distinct kinds
of positive emotions? Right?
So this was this new generation of
research as trying to look at distinct
autonomic profiles for different
positive emotions. And then finally,
is there evidence, action,
support of emotion coherence,
which is thought to be a core part of
the basic definition for what is an
emotion and what sort of individual
difference factors might influence this
relationship.
So what kinds of people have the lowest
coherence and what kinds of people might
have the highest coherence.
Okay.
And today I want to conclude with our
expert interview as part of the experts
and emotion interview series.
Okay.
So today as part of our series
we'll be speaking with um,
doctor Robert Levenson from the
University of California Berkeley,
who is going to be speaking with us
about this question that's guided much of
our discussion today. Blood
tears, sweat and fears,
the autonomic nervous system and emotion.
So doctor Levinson received his phd
from Vanderbilt University in clinical
psychology and he's currently a professor
in the Department of Psychology at the
University of California Berkeley,
where he's a member of both the
behavioral neuroscience, clinical science,
developmental and social
personality programs.
He currently serves as the
director of the institute,
or a personality in social research,
as well as the director of
the clinical science program.
So Dr Levinson's research program is in
the area of human emotion studying the
Organization of physiological,
behavioral, and subjective systems.
The way that these systems are impacted
by neuropathology normal aging and
culture,
and the role that emotions play in the
maintenance and disruption of committed
relationships.
Dr Levinson's research has been
supported by grants from the NIH and Nia,
and he is the past
president of the Society for
psychophysiological research and
the past president of the association
for Psychological Science.
So I now turn to a very special experts
in emotion interview with Doctor Robert
Levenson from the University
of California Berkeley.
Okay.